[Music]
is responsible for having otto warmbier
return to this country and be reunited
with his family in his final hours
before he passed but the president is
talking about that chairman Kim did not
know what happened to Otto at the time
of what happened when it happened
Kelly and Conway this is the cleanup
Brigade once again it was very clear
what the president said it was
despicable comment he has said that he's
got this love affair with kim jung-han
who's a brutal dictator who's
responsible for the death of otto
warmbier we shouldn't be naive about
this regime and about the way they
mistreat their own people and certainly
the way they mistreated out of warmbier
let's bring on a panel to talk about
this in more Jason Reilly Wall Street
Journal columnist and senior fellow at
the Manhattan Institute Charles Lane
opinion writer for The Washington Post
and matthew cottan Eddy editor-in-chief
of the Washington free beacon gentlemen
welcome to all of you so let's start
here otto warmbier as parents obviously
have had to watch as president Trump has
had praise for Kim Jong on in certain
respects talked about their close
relationship how good of friends that
they are and have become they put out a
statement saying we've been respectful
during this summit process now we must
speak out Kim and his evil regime are
responsible for the death of our son
Otto Kim and his evil regime are
responsible for unimaginable cruelty and
inhumanity no excuses or lavish praise
can change that Jason and it's not only
their opinion it's what US intelligence
officials have found as well I think the
White House realizes they needed to walk
this back and that's what you're seeing
happening right now and I think it's
it's the right thing to do the Kim
jong-un who basically took the position
that the crown prince of Saudi Arabia
took which is these were rogue
underlings I really didn't know anything
about it I'm very very sorry
but we all know in countries like North
Korea and Saudi Arabia nothing happens
without the leadership at the top
knowing about it so they are obviously
lying about this so this is the
president put out two tweets this
afternoon he says I never liked being
misinterpreted but especially when it
comes to otto warmbier and his great
family remember
I got Otto out along with three others
the previous administration did nothing
and he was taken on there
of course I hold North Korea responsible
for Otto's mistreatment and death most
important otto warmbier will not have
died in vain Otto and his family have
become a tremendous symbol of strong
passion and strength which will last for
many years into the future I love Otto
and think of him often and Chuck that
gets to this this question about yes he
is saying this is North Korea's fault
but he's not willing to directly
attribute knowledge of it to Kim he
never has actually even when he was
talking about this in a State of the
Union address I believe it was 2018
where he said we pledge to honor Otto's
memory with American resolve he only
talked about the dictatorship he's been
trying to sort of shield Kim from blame
to this for this all along the the thing
that was different this time was a sort
of he seemed to go an extra step and
assert that oh he wouldn't have wanted
to do that because it wouldn't have been
to his advantage he was kind of talking
about talking about Kim it's almost like
lawyering on his behalf this has been a
chronic problem for Donald Trump ever
since he declared his candidacy is the
way he talks about the human rights
abuses of other countries and he tends
to relativize them he Thames
he tends to speak of them in morally
exculpatory terms whether it's the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
strangely enough an old enemy like North
Korea or even saying suggesting that the
United States kills a lot of people too
he is not over that problem well in
Matthew he he gets on a heat also for
the Helsinki situation with Putin and
saying I believe him when he tells me
they didn't interfere in the 2016
election for him it seems that he's very
relational these relationships of the
foreign leaders are the key for him he
thinks to eventually be able to get
important concessions for the US and it
seems his strategy is he's not going to
insult them directly because that's how
he believes he gets the deal done the
strategy is personal diplomacy but I
think he kind of found the limits of
personal diplomacy in this second summit
where he really tried the charm approach
tried to talk up his love of Kim jong-un
and it still didn't get him the deal and
so as he conducts this attempt to
really kind of promote peace in the
Korean Peninsula I think we've moved
beyond the nuclear denuclearization we
just want a ratcheting down of tensions
he has to keep in mind who Kim is and
who the North Korean regime are and they
are the world's most chronic and
terrible violators of human rights okay
that's just one hot point for the issue
for the president this week because the
contrast to his efforts in North Korea
was of course Michael Cohen being here
on Capitol Hill again behind closed
doors and in public as well we want to
get some reaction from both sides of the
aisle in the house I think we all feel
it was a very productive interview today
where he was able to shed light on a lot
of issues that are very core to our
investigation and we were able to drill
down and in great detail the Democrats
intention is for this investigation to
go through 2020 into the next election
there's no question about it and if they
don't find evidence occlusion which they
haven't or obstruction which they
haven't then they look for something
else and that's something else maybe the
president's tax returns because Mike
Emanuel just reported moments ago
forwarding something from a spokesperson
for Nancy Pelosi and Speaker of the
House saying that they'll do everything
necessary including litigation whatever
they have to do to get to the president
tax returns here's part of it in
proprieties and the lack of transparency
around them referring to the president
give the house legitimate legislative
oversight and legal reasons to review
the president's tax returns they go on
to talk about getting those they say
will take all necessary steps including
litigation if we have to to get them
Jason the Democrats now control more
than two dozen committees with oversight
responsibilities and they are just
getting started they are coming after
tax returns they're coming after the
Trump family that Trump business the
Trump foundation they are setting the
ground work here for impeachment that is
the ultimate goal and these
investigations are not about really
finding anything new it's about volume
how many can we go go with here keep
them running right through the election
that is the goal and I think that the
president and the administration is
going to be in a defensive Crouch from
now until 2020 because of it Chuck is
this about though embarrassing the
president because we know there's not
going to be a line on the tax report or
tax return that says
$500,000 from Vladimir Putin I mean
that's not gonna be there but are they
trying to go after him with respect to
his assets and his bragging about how
well he's done and how successful he is
financially I gotta believe that if
these tax returns reflected extremely
well and he would have put him into the
public domain he has had this strange
aversion to doing what every other
presidential candidate and president has
done in the past
he is unlike any other no no question
ensure the return is a stack this high
still he long ago a normal president
would have revealed them and so there's
got to be something in there that he
doesn't want people to see and you know
sooner or later maybe we will see it I I
tend to slightly disagree with Jason I'm
not sure impeachment is the Democrats
endgame here I think to the contrary I
think in some ways this is a substitute
for impeachment this is a situation
where they can they have so much to work
with it and keep it going all the way
through as mr. Stewart said all the way
through twenty can walk reelection I'm
quickly Matthew Congress is a nuisance
the real danger is the Southern District
of New York yeah that's going to be a
lot of headache probably for the
president we'll talk about that as well